[Music]
I'm Anthony here on the floor of Google
Cloud next 2023 with Stan Stan could you
introduce yourself yep Stan Rock I'm
from open text is a principal uh
technology architect and Stan I'm so
happy you're here with me because I
would love to learn what are your
favorite Parts about working with Google
Cloud I love working with Google Cloud
for the developer experience and and and
that term can mean a lot or different
things to different people so how would
you define the developer experience I
think it's hard to really put it into
concrete words but I do like the inter
Loop development with Cloud
workstations and some of the other uh
partners that are also here at Cloud
next that help the inner loop and outer
loop experience absolutely so Stan what
are you most excited to build next with
Google Cloud um I've got a couple
projects coming up but mostly Focus
focused around assured workloads and uh
Beyond cor awesome I mean I think like
uh when it comes to building uh what's
next it's always nice to build net new
features but improving our security
posture is something that we should
always be working on so very very
excited to hear that and they both
actually help with security posture and
then in compliance for other regions and
yeah absolutely I mean it's something
that we want our users and you want your
users to not have to think about so I
love that work well thanks so much and
really appreciate
it my name is B I am a software
architect in the open tax team that's
awesome I'm so excited that you're here
with us today I just had a couple quick
questions for you I would love to hear
what your favorite parts of working with
Google Cloud are sure so my favorite
part is really the ecosystem the the
fact that you you are able to take
advantage of all this uh technology we
are using kuet obviously we are using
the VM technology and also everything
that's building on top of it obviously
we're Tak advantage of the AI technology
we're trying to integrate part of our
product as well as the platform that
we're building for our own self right
and as an architect I can see how you
are kind of uh looking across all the
layers of of your company's technology
stack so um given that could you tell me
about what you're most excited to build
next sure so obviously we are a Content
Service uh company so we are really
excited to take advantage of the AI so
that we can do a lot of things that uh
our customer have uh into our platform
the data um whether not it is a you know
PDF or the the document the legal
document all these stuff that they have
in our platform we want to take
advantage of AI so that we can we can
help them to do their job better but at
the same time what we want to do is do
our job better as well and this is where
AI is going to come in as well where
whether or not it's our platform our
engineering team all those things we
really hope to be able to take advantage
of those Technologies yeah and I think
the thing that stood out to me there is
that you led with your users right at
the end of the day I come from a
kubernetes background we love to build
lower level infrastructure but at the
end of the day what matters is the value
it's delivering to users so I'm really
glad to hear that that was top of mind
for you um and I'm excited to see what
you build so thank you for taking the
time to talk to us thank you all right
thank
[Music]
you